[Music]
Ralph breaks the Internet just came out
and it is epic it's one of Disney's most
ambitious films and a lot went into the
making of it we've got 10 secrets you
probably missed from the new movie are
you a total Disney fanatic like we are
for more awesome videos like this be
sure to subscribe now let's check out
those 10 secrets from Ralph breaks the
internet the original princesses people
have been excited for the Disney
Princesses to make an appearance ever
since a clip from the movie dropped and
every princess including unofficial ones
like Elsa and Anna is in the movie it's
pretty amazing but one of the coolest
parts is that almost all of the
princesses have their original voice
actors besides the old school ones Snow
White Cinderella and Aurora every Disney
voice actor came back to voice their
princess even Ariel and Belle from
almost 30 years ago where she took your
voice in exchange for a pair of human
legs not some of the newer princesses
have more famous voices but we got to
hear all of our favorites
we love that they didn't try to replace
these princesses it was a perfect
tribute to all our favorite movies a
Jewish princess ever since the mid-1990s
Disney has made an effort to make their
characters more diverse with Pocahontas
Mulan Tiana and Moana little girls
everywhere feel like they can be
princesses too but until Jewish comedian
Sarah Silverman gave her voice to
princess vanellope von schweetz we never
had a Jewish princess Silverman takes a
lot of pride in her Jewish heritage and
she tried to bring all her best traits
to vanellope she has said it's great to
have a Jewish princess because there
never was one when she was growing up
princesses come in all shapes and sizes
and we love that message original
animators Disney has been around for a
very long time and many of the great
animators are still around it was a
pretty big task to bring back Disney
characters that have been around for so
long and have them feel authentic but
the animators of wreck-it Ralph did just
that one of the original supervising
animators
five of the Disney Princesses was on
staff to help bring the princess crew
back Mark Ken was the genius behind
Ariel Belle jasmine Mulan and Tiana he
was there every step of the way to help
the newer younger animators make this
movie epic it's got to be great to work
with some of the biggest names in Disney
ever it must be a dream come true just
like vanilla peas dream for exciting
races Mario reference in the first
wreck-it Ralph we get to see a ton of
classic videogame characters like
pac-man and Sonic the Hedgehog and while
they reference Mario the iconic plumber
turned hero never makes an appearance he
didn't exactly make an appearance in the
sequel either but there was a very
subtle reference you might have missed
when Ralph and vanellope first look out
over the World Wide Web there is a
hologram toadstool shooting out of
Rainbow Road classic Mario fans will
totally get this reference
maybe one day Mario will get a Disney
cameo until then we'll just keep looking
for Easter eggs drawing frenzy Ralph
breaks the Internet is one ambitious
film it attempts to make social
commentary on internet culture through
tons of jokes it succeeds it has
messages about friendship and so many
pop-culture references we couldn't keep
track a movie this huge had a lot of
work to go into it did you know that
there were 280 3839 drawings that went
into this sequel how insane is that most
of them did get thrown out but what made
it into the movie is amazing working on
a movie like Ralph breaks the Internet
must have been so much fun
post-credit scenes if you watched all
the trailers for a Ralph's breaks the
internet you were probably pretty
excited to see Ralph overstep a bunny in
an online game but that scene didn't
make it into the main part of the movie
we hate it when that happens but so does
Disney they included this scene in the
first post-credit scene and they threw
in a joke about how disappointing it is
when a scene from a trailer isn't in the
film we love that they can laugh at
themselves how about that second
post-credit scene we don't want to spoil
it for you but it was not what we
expected at all did you stay to watch
the extra
scenes they were so worth it keep
watching for our favorite secret from
the new movie so many Easter eggs it's
impossible to know how many Easter eggs
and pop-culture references are in
Ralph's breaks the Internet there are so
many that even if filmmakers aren't sure
how many there are according to Larry Wu
the head of environments they had
several meetings to comb the film and
make lists of all of them but they know
they missed some because different
animators sneaked in little secrets
where should you look for the most
Easter eggs watch the eBay scene and oh
my Disney scene carefully and see how
many you can find some you would never
guess like animators names Loftus
Steiner one of the most subtle secrets
is found in the billboard at the very
beginning and very end of the movie we
are shown outside of the arcade behind
it is a billboard for Loftus Steiner
that seems like a weird random name for
a breakfast place don't you think how
did the animators come up with that the
answer is in the credits
Cory Loftus is the production designer
for a route breaks the Internet he's so
important that he gets his very first
and very last Easter egg in the movie if
those sneaky animators do you think
Loftus put it in the movie himself or
was someone trying to impress their boss
owed to Wikipedia the amount of Internet
jokes and references in Ralph's breaks
the Internet is insane
there are birds that tweet on Twitter
IMDB and Fandango show up Google is
nearly taken down by wreck-it ralph
virus and the giant pin from Pinterest
is used as a weapon we see all our
favorite websites and apps mentioned and
no internet movie would be complete
without a reference to wikipedia the
free encyclopedia is obviously very
important to the animators toward the
end of the movie when Ralph and
vanellope are trying to stop the virus
we see a huge statue honoring Wikipedia
it's literally put on a pedestal we know
we know Wikipedia is great but we aren't
sure we dedicate a statue to it would
you the gang's all here most of our
favorite characters from wreck-it Ralph
we're back fix-it Felix and Captain
Calhoun are happily married tapper and
sour bill are still around mr. Litvak is
still voiced by Ed O'Neill even taffeta
voiced by Mindy Kaling returned for the
sequel but the crazy villain from the
first movie King candy aka turbo met his
demise but his voice actor returned as a
new character Alan Tudyk played no
more the searchbar guy we're so happy
that he got to come back in their new
movie I'm sorry but my autofill is a
touch aggressive today what was your
favorite part of brows breaks the
internet let us know in the comments
below and that's it for the 10 secrets
from Ralph breaks the internet check out
our community page for more great
content and don't forget to subscribe
see you next time
[Music]